I'm John Nelson and I am an assistant scoutmaster with Truth 947 in Westchester Ohio.
This edition of the Scoutmasters podcast is sponsored by backers like me.
And now it's the old scoutmaster.
We had an event with the Scouts this weekend.
I thought it was a little bit like being at the Olympics.
We had no electrical power and the water was a little dodgy. and you know the facility.
No, really.
Three-time Olympian and 1998 gold medalist, competitive skier Peek-a-Boo Street.
You'll remember that name from past Olympics.
Now she's broadcasting from the Sochi Olympics.
She's done a lot of charity work in her retirement from skiing,
Perhaps most notably helping establish an intensive care unit at a local hospital.
I love to see people do things like that.
You know what they call the intensive care unit, don't you?
Yeah, it's the Peek-a-Boo ICU.
Sorry,
I just couldn't help myself.
Hey, this is podcast number 208..
Hey,
Hey.
Well, welcome back to the Scoutmaster Podcast.
This is Clark Green.
Let's take a look at the mailbag.
This Chaplain, who is the advisor for Venture Crew number 1833, sent me this saying:
Scout troops are like a pair of shoes.
A scout needs to find one that best fits.
But even the best fitting shoe can give you blisters every once in a while
Nice thought James.
Nice thought
Frank N is a Scoutmaster with Albertus Troop 86.
And he wrote in to say: like yourself, I was never a boy scout.
I became involved as a result of my two boys enrolling in the program.
I'm currently on my third year of scouting,
having served as a committee member, assistant scoutmaster
and now da-da-da Scoutmaster.
As I navigate my way through scouting,
I look for websites that provide useful information
and help me maintain the momentum we've created.
I have found that website at scoutmastercgcom.
Keep up the good work.
Thanks, Frank.
I'm glad you're finding what we have available useful to you
And good on you for volunteering for scouting.
Bob Taylor wrote in to say
I really enjoy your blog posts and podcasts.
I recently purchased the iPhone app
and I'm starting to work through the archive podcast.
Thanks for what you do.
That's right.
We have the Scoutmaster CG app that puts all of the blog posts
and the podcasts and all the information that we share
right there at your fingertips.
It's available at the iTunes store
And it's also available for Android devices through Google Play.
Randy Green wrote in to say
I'm glad I found your site.
I have it bookmarked.
There's a wealth of information there.
I'm always trying to educate young people
I come in contact with by getting them to think analytically
and to show them skills to be self-sufficient
and help others.
I was looking at your top 10 fire starters infographic
and I have one to add:
a bottle cap-sized piece of sap
that can often be found on evergreen trees.
You can dip a few twigs in it
and they'll burn longer.
Keep up the good work of assisting,
raising responsible young people.
Thank you, Randy.
Thanks for the idea.
I'm going to give that a shot.
I'm going to check that out.
Last week on podcast 207,
we started talking about difficult behavior
and I had a couple of responses to that.
One listener asked to remain anonymous,
wrote in to say
I think I have a pretty good handle
on my ex-games type of guy,
But you shed even more light
that will help me as a parent.
I can't tell you how much I look forward to part two:
Consequences that work
and that fall within BSA guidelines.
I know my kid.
he needs boundaries,
he needs consequences,
but mostly he needs something to do
and to feel a bit important.
Well, I have to agree with you.
I think that's true of all of our scouts.
They need boundaries,
they need consequences,
but they need meaningful things to do
that build them up,
And we're going to be talking about that
a little bit later on in the podcast.
Also, this past week
in our green bar life section
we published a series of three articles
by Enoch Highsey
about dealing with scout chaos.
Scout chaos is one of my favorite subjects.
I couldn't help but
as I was going through those articles,
of thinking of you know
the old get smart show,
But that kind of dates me
and you too,
if you just giggled at that.
So anyway,
Dan Nudeswig left a comment
about that series.
It says many times a disruptive scout
is a boy trying to get attention
and show others he's knowledgeable and able.
I try to give him a platform to do that
in a constructive manner.
If we're working on skills,
we ask him to demonstrate them
and to help the other scouts with them.
Dan, excellent idea
about channeling that kind of chaotic,
maybe sometimes disruptive energy
that we see so often.
It's a whole lot better than stopping it.
I think one of the big messages we get out of those articles
is channeling that chaos,
managing it, leading it,
not trying to stamp it out-
to accept that really powerful energy
and put it to work.
We also heard from Bill Stoll,
who said
great series of articles
and always an important subject.
The reason some troops have retention problems
is a stale or adult run, boring program.
I'm always looking for good ideas myself.
Make sure you take the opportunity,
if you haven't already,
to read the Managing Chaos series
that Enoch prepared for us.
I think you're going to like it a lot.
Well, over on ScoutMasterCGcom this week
we had a number of people sign up
and start participating
in the Scouter Forum that we have there.
Do go and check it out.
Right at the top of the page
there's a link that says
participate and under that
you can get yourself to the forums,
You can sign up
and you can begin joining in the discussion.
There's been some interesting things
about working with youth leaders
and about some high adventure ideas
that you might find interesting.
This coming Sunday,
February 16th,
between 9 and 10 pm
Eastern Standard Time,
we're going to have
a Scout Circle presentation
with the author of that series of articles
that we were just talking about,
Enoch Hysie.
Enoch was a patrol leader,
senior patrol leader,
youth leader in his troop.
He's a very thoughtfully young man,
a great writer,
and he is heading up
the Green Bar Life section
of ScoutMasterCGcom.
We're going to get him to join us
on the February Scout Circle
and discuss some of the things
that he's been writing about,
And this would be a great Scout Circle
to have some of your youth leadership see.
So once again, Sunday,
February 16th,
9 to 10 pm Eastern Standard Time.
Come to ScoutMasterCGcom
and follow the links
to find our February Scout Circle.
It'll be a presentation that's followed up
by a question and answer period
and discussion period
with the people who are watching.
The Scout Circle presentation,
like everything else we're doing,
is sponsored by our ScoutMasterCG backers.
Now, if you're a regular reader
and a listener
and what we are offering has helped out,
you can return the favor
by helping keep things up and running
by becoming a backer.
Funds from backers go towards the expenses
of producing and publishing the blog,
the posts, the podcasts,
the videos, the presentations
that are proving to be a valuable resource.
We want to keep them freely accessible
for Scouters all over the world.
I want to welcome
Ty Schwerferger, Michael Smith
and Patricia Koch
as new ScoutMasterCGcom backers,
Thank you.
Thank you so very much
for your support
Now in this podcast
and ScoutMasterShip, in seven minutes
or less,
which will be much longer
than seven minutes,
as it usually is.
Oh my,
The second part
of talking about
Scouts and Difficult Behavior,
and then we have some
email questions to answer
And that's going to take up
the rest of the entire podcast.
So let's get started, shall we
ScoutMasterShip in seven minutes
or less.
Now, last week,
in part one of this two-part series,
we began discussing
difficult behavior in Scouts.
Just to catch everybody out,
there are times when Scouts
just kind of lose their way
and they aren't aware
of what's happening around them.
They're kind of just walking
underwater,
And anybody who's been around a group
of Scouts on a Sunday morning
during a weekend camping trip
knows exactly what I'm talking about.
We know that Scouts sometimes
unknowingly misbehaved.
They're not aware of the rules
or the right way to do things
And they just kind of charge ahead
and all that exuberance
and energy that they have.
We know that Scouts sometimes
deliberately misbehaved,
That they are aware of the rules
or the right things to do,
but they make a bad choice
And we know that every once in a while
a Scout does something
that is so just
unaccountably foolish and reckless.
We find ourselves asking
how such an intelligent kid
could do something so stupid.
Now we also discussed last week
why they act this way.
We know that physically
our Scouts- especially when they're camping,
they need plenty of sleep
and plenty of food
and plenty of water,
And I would never, ever discount
those physical factors
as the source of difficult behavior.
Those are a lot of times
kind of easy to fix.
We know that mentally
they need some expectations
and they need some boundaries
and they need to stay engaged-
And that's always a challenge.
And we know that spiritually,
they need to develop
an internal standard of behavior
that guides their actions,
And much of our work as Scouts
is aimed at forming
and maturing
that internal standard of behavior.
Now, any experienced Scouter
or parent will tell you
that asking adolescents
to contemplate the trade-offs
between risks and benefits
is not going to be all that effective
in a lot of instances,
because we know that their
decision-making capabilities
are not yet developed
And we're working hard
to help them develop them right.
But sometimes
just this kind of logical statement
of the facts
and reasoning that adults
try to impose on young people
is not going to help
Because, as we learned last week,
the decision-making in those
adolescent brains is skewed
towards overestimating the benefits
of an action
and underestimating bad outcomes
If they view that some kind
of action or decision is going to
make them look cool
is going to improve their status
in the minds of their peers.
that's a very, very powerful benefit
that they perceive,
And sometimes
no amount of rational thinking
is going to overcome that,
Because what seems rational
and well-regioned to us
is not going to have the same effect
on them.
Now, experience is a good teacher,
but experience based on negative
results is not quite
as effective in
children and younger adolescents
as it is in older adolescents
and adults.
These things all kind of converge
and make risk-taking
very attractive to adolescent boys.
Remember that you're not dealing
with a fully-formed, rational
adult.
So how do we help
our scouts make
better decisions when it comes to
risky or difficult behavior?
Well, risky and difficult behavior
is going to have less appeal
if scouts see a direct benefit
from the alternative,
safer courses of action.
The benefits of choices in their minds
outweigh the negative consequences
of choices.
So we can leverage that
by making sure that we put a lot of
weight on the benefit of good decisions,
And one of the ways we can do that
is make sure that we promote
positive images of good decision-making.
We can help them build confidence
to recognize and reject
risky behavior and to get
themselves out of risky situations.
Our monitoring and supervision
is going to limit
exposure to risky situations,
And that's a challenge in scouting,
because monitoring is supervision,
so that real responsibility is present
on the part of the scouts and
real choices are able to be made.
And finally, one very important
way we can help
our scouts manage risk
is making sure that they are occupied
with positive activities.
I believe in downtime
and I believe in sitting around the campfire,
kind of hanging out with your pals,
And I don't think every single moment of the day needs to be scheduled.
by making positive activities
attractive and
keeping their time filled with them,
We really cut back on the possibilities
for poor decision-making.
So let's talk about rulemaking
for a moment. I've never seen much use
in troops establishing elaborate codes of
conduct or disciplinary rules
and regulations. We already have that.
It's built into scouting. We have the
scout oath and the scout law.
That's our code. If we
use the scout oath and the scout law
as our rules of conduct,
then we are able to
deal with scouts individually
based on their understanding of the scout oath
and the scout law.
And we deal with scouts individually
based on their understanding-
not ours, but their understanding-
of the scout oath and law.
We counsel with them and we work with them,
We build
an internal standard of behavior
that will not only apply to scouts
but will apply to the rest of their lives.
And when it comes to rulemaking,
we also need to remember
that scouts are much more motivated
by the promise of rewards
than they are discouraged by the threat
of punishment. Set rules
and regulations for punishment,
you know, zero tolerance policies
and things like that Prevent us
from doing the work that is most important,
and that is dealing with scouts
on an individual basis
and thus building that internal standard.
Baden Powell
had a couple of things to say about this.
He said it's risky to order
a boy not to do something.
It immediately opens to him the adventure
of doing it. He also said
the boy is not governed by
don't but is led
by do. I think
the scout oath and law are
powerful tools for positive reinforcement.
The only tools we have
in our toolbox are positive.
Try it. Instead of telling everybody
what's prohibited, tell them what's expected.
Remember negative reinforcement.
once again, it's a weak
method for scout age boys
and I don't think it's consistent with the values of the scout oath and law.
The scout oath and law
is not a set of prohibitions,
It's a set of aspirations
And if we are consistently
aiming at the aspirations,
the prohibitions take care of themselves.
So now we understand
something about the sources
of difficult behavior. We know
some of the causes involved.
We know that we want to use
strong, positive reinforcement
whenever possible. We know that there are
things that we can do to minimize
possibility of bad
decision making and risky behavior.
But you know what's coming next. right,
If we get everything
right and we're still
working very, very hard on
all of these fronts, we
understand that at some point
we're going to be dealing with
risky or difficult behavior in our
scouts. So how do we
react? If we understand
the way that things work
with scouts, we know
that reactive punishment
is going to have little effect
on their future ability to make
better decisions, And that's what
we're aimed at: building the internal
standards so they can make better
decisions. Anger or punishments
are weak tools and may
even make scouts even more
recalcitrant and drive them
towards more risky behavior or bad
decisions. Now, a boys will
be boys attitude is
absolutely not an option,
But neither is reacting with anger
or punishment. A more empathetic
and compassionate and useful approach
is learning about
why they made
a bad decision or why
they participated in a risky behavior.
We do that by learning a little
bit more about how
they look at the world And then we
apply that understanding
to helping them manage risky situations
and reacting rationally
rather than emotionally
when they make bad choices of action.
When we run into problems. we need
to differentiate between proportionate
consequences
and corrective punishment.
This is a really important distinction.
Proportionate consequences are
the direct result of misbehavior.
So sitting out
an activity that you disrupted,
or being restricted from using something
like a knife that was
misused, resolving a conflict
caused by bad behavior,
cleaning up a mess caused
by difficult behavior-
that's proportionate consequences.
It deals with
things that are a direct result
of the behavior.
Corrective punishment,
on the other hand, is any
sanction beyond
those proportionate consequences
A very important distinction,
I am going to say.
in my opinion,
scouters and youth leaders
should never apply
corrective punishment.
I talked about that a moment ago.
Systems of corrective punishments,
such as demerits or forced physical
activity like pushups or the like,
are completely out of place in scouting.
That kind of a system of rules and sanctions
requires enforcement and policing,
and scouters and youth leaders
are not enforcers
and they're not police.
If we meet
difficult behavior with constructive discipline
that determines
the appropriate consequences,
we're going to be much more successful.
We need to counsel the scout
and discuss the behavior
And in that counseling we separate
the behavior from the scout.
We work together to determine
what proportionate consequences there are.
Let's talk very specifically
about some steps that we
would take in response to difficult behavior.
Number one:
we intervene immediately to stop
anything that is injurious to individuals
or damaging to property.
We just immediately stop that.
Number two is: once we've stopped
whatever is going on,
we have to take the time
to quiet our own emotional response.
I know I do and I'm going to
guess that you do too.
Of course, this is really difficult. a lot of the time,
If we respond emotionally,
it's likely scouts are going to view
the consequences of their poor decision
as something that upset us,
rather than
the consequences being a direct
result of the decision that they made.
I want to spend a moment talking
about quieting that emotional response.
A lot of times you're going to need somebody
to help you do that. You're going to need to
grab a fellow scatter and say I am really upset
right now and I need you to talk to me
for a moment until I get over this.
A couple of things that will
help you think your way through this
is remember that what's happening
is part of a developmental process.
We've all made plenty of
bad decisions in the past ourselves,
So it's
important to understand that
what's going on is not
intended to hurt you,
nor it is indicative of the quality
or value of your service. as a
scouter. We have to be
very careful not to take these
things too personally. So once
we've stopped whatever was going on
and quieted our own emotional
response, we need to start
asking questions. We need to get to
the heart of the matter. We need to
listen carefully to the answers.
and once we've listened carefully to the answers,
we can help scouts discover
the moral and ethical principles
that bear on the situation.
We're not going to do this when we're
emotional. We're not going to do this
without doing a lot of listening,
And we're not going to do this by preaching
to the scouts. We're going to do this by
asking questions. We're going to reserve
issuing judgment and we're going to ask
the scouts to judge themselves.
That way, we're invoking
that developing internal standard of behavior.
Here's an example. okay,
Let's say a scout on a dare
collapses a fellow scout's
tent at summer camp.
That's going to make me emotional and crazy.
I'm going to make sure first that there's no more
injury or damage possible.
I'm going to step away. I'm going to take
a couple of deep breaths. I'm going to
count to ten. I'm going to talk to one
of my fellow scouters. Then I'm going to
sit down with the scout and I'm going to ask
the scout to come in there. He's going to tell me
something like: well, I knocked John's
tent down. I'm going to say: well,
why did you do that? He may be angry
and upset and embarrassed at the whole
situation. He might be a little recalcitrant.
He's going to say: well, I don't know.
I'm going to reply. I have a hard time
believing that you just suddenly decided
that this was a good idea. Tell me
what you were thinking. The scout's not
going to be happy about talking to me.
He's going to say: I don't know,
Nobody suggested this would be a good idea.
It came to you on your own and maybe
he'll allow that. the other guys may have
edged him on a little bit. I'm going to ask
him if what he did
turned out to be a very good idea.
He's going to say: I don't think so.
I'm going to tell him that I agree
and I'm going to ask him to think of
what points of the scout law
he may have forgotten for a moment.
and you know he's going to love
this.
He's going to look at me
and he's going to say, well,
I don't know, because he doesn't
want to talk about this. You know,
really, You don't know.
No, I don't know. I just kind
of did it. I'll say, all right,
well, listen, you need some time to think
about this. if you aren't ready to talk to me now,
Why don't you sit right here and wait
for a while? I can be back in 15 or 20
minutes. Usually, the idea of
sitting there and waiting for me to come
back is not very attractive.
So that might loosen them up a little bit
and I'm going to get something like: well,
I knew what I was doing was wrong,
but it's no big deal.
I won't do it again.
I'm sorry, Leave me alone.
I said: well, you know, it's kind of a big deal.
It's a big deal to me, It's a big deal
to the guy whose tent you knocked over.
Can you understand that? that would be
really upsetting.
Well, yeah, I kind of understand. Well,
how are you going to make it right? Well,
I could apologize. Okay,
Is there anything else? Yeah, I can set
the tent back up, All right, look,
listen to me, I think you got it right.
I know the last thing you want to do
is be sitting here talking to me about
this, but I can't ignore what
you're doing. Need to apologize, Need to
set the tent back up, But before we're
finished, I need you to think about
and tell me what part of the scout
law you forgot when you did
this. Well, maybe I forgot to be
trustworthy. Maybe I forgot to be friendly.
Maybe I forgot to be kind.
Okay, see, that
was easy, right, I know you knew that.
Listen, we all forgot ourselves
once in a while and we do
things we regret. Can I
trust you to go ahead and make this right
and not to repeat it, please?
Well, yeah, I suppose. so
I knew I could count on you
and the next time we talk, let's
have something better to talk about. Now,
that's an idealized conversation,
Okay, and of course,
I was perfectly level-headed
and consistent all the way
through it. It's not always going to
happen. I work hard at trying
to concentrate:
getting the scout to think through
the action, getting them to identify
what the proportionate consequences
of that action ought to be
and getting them to analyze
their decision in the
light of the scout oath and law.
A scout who behaves poorly
is not going to be real thrilled about getting
caught. They're going to be upset
and angry. They'll be reacting
emotionally. Now, compounding
that emotional reaction with
my own is the way that we have
really ugly scenes
and difficulties. If we take
the time we quiet the emotional
reaction, we don't start
issuing judgments, we start
asking questions and we
work by being empathetic
and finding something
complimentary to say about the scout,
separating him from the behavior.
You know I expect more
from you. I know I can expect
more from you. I know that this was a mistake,
so let's not let it happen again.
Okay, that can be really challenging,
but if you work at it
you'll make it happen. If we learn
how to be disappointed in
behavior without being
disappointed in a scout- and that
can take some learning- we can
start exercising
positive reinforcement.
We want our scouts to do better
and we don't achieve that
by making them feel worse.
Bad behavior diminishes
if we make a habit of looking
for and recognizing
good behavior, If we
exercise positive reinforcement.
a few words of honest
praise from somebody you respect
are a really powerful force for good.
So I know what you're thinking.
that all sounds well and good.
I'll give it a shot. but what happens
if a scout keeps misbehaving?
What if that guy you're talking about
went ahead and kept on knocking
down tents? What if the behavior
was very serious and it damaged
something or injured someone?
Repetitive or serious bad behavior
is something that now
we're going to discuss with
the scout and with their
parent. We're going to go through the
steps I described in:
learning about what was going on
and finding out what the
proportionate consequences are and everything like that.
but we're going to leave it up to
parents to employ
any kind of corrective punishment.
and you know, it's actually
pretty simple. We had a little trouble
on the camping trip. Your son
needs to explain what this trouble was.
we have sorted
it out as far as we're concerned.
but any correction that you feel you need
to do at home once you understand
what went on
would help back us up,
and parents will usually respond pretty positively
to that. What happens
when we go through those steps
and we still have misbehavior?
Well, we're going to go back to the parents
and we're going to say this behavior
hasn't been addressed properly. We're doing our best,
we've done everything that we can do,
but it's time for you to step in
and you're going to have to make
whatever corrections you're going to need
or your son's not going to be able to continue to participate
until you assure us
that that behavior isn't going to be repeated.
So there's this kind of
three-tiered approach. A lot of behavior
we can handle. We can handle it at the moment
and we can resolve it.
There can be proportionate consequences to it.
If it's repetitive or really
risky or dangerous, parents
need to be involved. They need to
impose any corrective punishment
that they feel is appropriate.
If, after those two steps,
we're still having a behavior problem,
it's very plain
and it needs to be laid out
to a set of parents. Look, this behavior
is still continuing
and until you can assure us
that you've corrected it and your son
can come back and participate
with scouts and not continue
to misbehave, he's not going to be able
to participate From right now.
until I have your personal assurance
that this behavior isn't going to be repeated,
he won't be able to participate in meetings
or campouts. And you know
the discussion is probably not going to be quite that simple,
but that's my opinion
and my suggestion of how to proceed
in that kind of extreme situation.
So how many times do we come across
a situation that extreme?
I will tell you in my personal experience
it's very rare: Not once a year,
not once every five years.
And the rarity of that is owing to the fact
that we use positive reinforcement,
that we use
the Scout Oath and Law
as our standard of behavior,
that we don't have a big set of rules
and regulations and demerits
and whatever, And we counsel our Scouts
to help them develop that internal
standard. Of course we're not perfect,
of course nobody's going to be perfect,
but hopefully these things about
difficult behavior will give you some tools
to work with that will help you
be a better Scouter and help you
achieve the aims of Scouting.
Watching how they love to sing.
there were mice- mice
eating up the rice in the stores.
in the stores
there were rats- rats
big as blooming cats
in the quarter master store.
my eyes are dim.
I cannot see.
I have not brought my specs
with me.
I have not brought
my specs
with me.
write me a letter,
send it by name
email. that is folks.
and here's an answer to one of your
emails.
Listener who has asked to remain anonymous
writes:
I have so many differing opinion
amongst the troops- adults-
that I can't decide whose ideas
to go with.
if I choose one group set of opinions
over another,
the other group isn't going to be happy.
I want to do what's right and good for the boys,
but other adults think their opinions
are better than mine.
how do I deal with these opinions
as a Scouter
and maintain a program for my Scouts?
any input you could provide
would be greatly appreciated.
I want to say this:
let's first understand
that the Scouting program is not subject
to what everybody feels it ought to be.
it's pretty well defined.
so that's the first standard.
if the opinions are outside
of what is the clearly defined
way that Scouting ought to happen,
that's pretty easy.
but Scouting is also pretty flexible
program
and it can be presented in different ways.
I liken it to the
like making a cup of coffee.
you can brew coffee in one of a dozen different ways
and you can present Scouting
in different ways
when it comes to coffee. whatever brewing process
you choose,
the end result is basically the same.
you're going to get a cup of coffee,
a dozen different troops can present the methods
of the program differently,
but if they're presenting the Scouting program,
results are going to be the same.
the aims of Scouting are going to be achieved
in individual Scouts.
so who gets to choose the way coffee is being made?
well, whoever is making the coffee
and the Scoutmaster chooses
how the program will be presented
in a Scout troop.
that's why we have a Scoutmaster.
if the committee was going to make every decision
about how the program was going to be presented,
or just a group of adults
were going to get together and they were going to present it
in the way that they thought was best,
we don't need a Scoutmaster, right,
but no, that's why we have a Scoutmaster.
that's why Scoutmasters get trained
and study about Scouting and understand the program.
they make those decisions.
lots of people want to be helpful
and, in the spirit of being helpful,
they want to share their ideas with you,
and some of them may insist
that they know absolutely the right way
to do things.
so when it comes to this,
I like to think about the Scoutmaster
as someone who trains
and mentors Scouts to lead themselves,
but leads adults.
there's an important distinction there.
right, you train
and mentor Scouts. you lead
adults. mentors,
counsel and suggest. they respond to the
initiative of the Scouts
leaders, tell people what to do
and how to do it and when to do it.
so when you're, if you're- a Scoutmaster
and you're faced with this kind of conflict,
you tell the other adults
politely and decisively
that, while you value their input,
you're the Scoutmaster and you're going to do the best
job possible to achieve the aims
of Scouting, according to what you know
and how you've been trained.
you would appreciate it if they would get with the program
and follow your lead.
now, most of us are not going to like
having that kind of a confrontation.
we're going to be concerned about alienating
or upsetting people.
I'm going to say: do it anyways,
in a polite but assertive and direct
manner, and the message implicit
in what you're saying is: back off,
I'm the leader, follow me.
in other words, you need to assert
your leadership, you need to take
direct action and you need to put people
in line. that's part of being a leader.
sometimes, once people understand
that you're leading, they'll
fall in line. if they can't follow,
quite honestly, they need to get out of
the way. if the majority of the people
involved with the troop disagree
with the way that you're applying
the program, it's time for
a new scout master. it's pretty
simple, right? if it's just a case of
there being a lot of different opinions
and people wanting to do things
one way instead of another, and things
like that. hey, it's
time to sit everybody down and say:
I'm the scout master, I'm
going to lead you, you're going to follow,
and we're going to work with the boys
to present the scouting program in the
best way I know possible. so that can
be a tricky situation, but I hope that
advice helps. Richard billion
is with troop 298
in Minneapolis, Minnesota,
and he wrote to say: our scout troop
is going to be growing soon. I have
three Eagles and two former
senior patrol leaders in a group of
older scouts. do you have any good ideas
for utilizing these scouts?
I want them to stay on board as
long as possible, so I'm looking
for some interesting ideas that
will interest them and help the troop
as well. I was thinking about making them
into troop guides, maybe even assistant
scout masters. well, Richard,
here's my advice to you: go to them,
sit down and ask them what would interest
them. now they may have no idea what
you're talking about, so make some suggestions
about how they can be heroes to younger
scouts. lay down a challenge, maybe.
hey guys, nobody's ever done it before,
but I'll bet, knowing your skills,
knowing what great scouts you are, if
you team up and work in it, you'll have
all of our new scouts to first class
by this time next year. how about it?
maybe you sit down and you ask them: if you
are a scout master, what would you do?
what do you think the next year should
offer our new scouts? how can you help
make that happen? you can say:
I really value you guys and the great
skills you've learned over the past few
years. how do you best see putting them
to use over the next few months?
so that puts you in the role
of mentoring and advising and
counseling, instead of trying to
make anybody try to do anything
or making them into anything.
make offers, encourage, cajole,
inspire and see how these guys
respond. I have a team of
four or five junior assistant scout
masters. they're between the ages of 16
and 17 and they do
all sorts of things. for the truth, at
that age they are having
increasingly limited amounts of time they
can spend with us, but when they are
there they make a difference and they
are pretty sharp guys. the secret
is letting them decide how they will
be involved and letting them define
what they want to do and then getting
out of the way and letting them do it.
Richard, I hope that helps. hey, if you have
a question or a concern, you can
get in touch with me and you're going to
find out how to do that in just a moment.
well, thanks for listening to this
208th edition
of the scout master podcast. here's
how to get in touch. start by
reading the blog at scoutmastercgcom
and, while you're there, you can subscribe
to receive updates to the blog by email.
you can also get the scout master cg
app on google play or in the itunes
app store and keep in touch
with us. that way, you can experience
the wonders of scoutmastercgcom
through the vast panorama
of social media outlets.
that's right. join the 4700
plus folks who like
scout master blog on facebook.
tweet along with the 930 tweeters on twitter,
pin the pultritudinous pictures
proffered publicly with 1300 other
prolific pinners on pinterest
and you can watch us at scoutmastercg
on youtube. or join the
400 odd folks who form
the exclusive scout master cg
circle on google plus.
but if you can't face facebook,
if twitter makes you bitter, if you got
no interest in pinterest, you
don't put the? u in youtube and you're a
minus when it comes to google plus. that's
alright, funky, zoom into
the late 90s and send me an email.
that's right. you can get in touch with me
at clark at scoutmastercgcom.
that's c-l-a-r-k-e
at scoutmastercgcom.
as ever, I remind you that the scoutmaster
blog and the scoutmaster podcast are not
official publications of the boy scouts of america,
nor are they endorsed
or sponsored by the boy scouts of america
or any other scouting organization for that matter.
they all have much better things to do.
it's just me talking into
a microphone, trying to lend a hand to scout leaders
and have a little bit of fun along the way,
and backing me up are all the
wonderful people who become scotmastercgcom
backers. and speaking of fun,
let's hear from our founder, sir robert
baton-pell. sir robert,
good luck to you and good camping.
why? thank you, sir,
until next time, everyone.